This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个由 iHeart 播客出品的节目。真人保证。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在这样一个陌生现代世界中培养精神坚韧性、体能以及建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”加百分号，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收听《回首过往》播客。从 1979 年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代那样。84 年是个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方，收听《回首过往》。嘿，你们好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的法则》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方进行都真的不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不。意味着你必须这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方，收听《艰难成长的法则》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方，收听《爱情陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》，这是一个我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化和转变及其含义的播客。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners. It's all about the listeners today, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another special, special episode as we break down the psychology of your 20s. It is coming to the end of 2024, only a couple of weeks away from the start of a new year. And with that in mind, I wanted one of the final episodes of the year to be something special, to be something a little bit different, and to be something that included you all, the listeners, you who have tuned in every single episode, you guys who have supported me so much this year and who have been in my corner as I announced my new book, as the show grew,
关于我们的心理学。大家好。欢迎回来。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎新老听众回到播客节目。今天的主角全是听众，无论你身处世界何地。非常高兴你能回来收听另一个特别、特别的节目，我们一起来剖析二十岁的心理学。2024 年即将结束，距离新年的开始只有短短几周了。考虑到这一点，我希望今年最后的几期节目能有点特别，有点与众不同，并且能把你们所有人都包含进来——听众们，你们每一集都准时收听，今年给予了我如此多的支持，并在我宣布新书、节目不断成长时一直站在我这边。
as I traveled when we did meetups. All of the best parts of this year really did include the community and included all of you who have just really been enjoying the show and been showing your love and support. And I thought, why not thank you guys? Why not thank you guys by making you one of the guests of our December guest segment? By giving the listeners an opportunity to come on, to be the guest to have their voices heard by other listeners.
当我出差去办听友见面会时。今年所有最美好的部分确实都包含了这个社区，也包含了所有真正喜欢这个节目、表现出你们的爱与支持的你们。我想，为什么不感谢你们呢？为什么不通过让你们成为我们 12 月听众环节的嘉宾之一来感谢你们呢？通过给听众一个机会，让他们上节目，成为嘉宾，让他们的声音被其他听众听到。
and also to answer some of your 20-something dilemmas. I get so many messages and DMs every single day recounting some of the things that you guys are all going through, some of the really confusing trials and tribulations and barriers that you're facing and breakups that you're going through and friendships that are falling apart and careers that are uncertain, so many questions. And just by the very nature of, you know,
还可以解答一些属于你们二十几岁的困惑。我每天都会收到无数的信息和私信，倾诉你们所有人正在经历的一些事情，你们面临的一些非常令人困惑的考验、磨难和障碍，以及你们正在经历的分手、分崩离析的友谊和不确定的职业生涯，有这么多的问题。仅仅因为……
know, having a large community, which I'm very grateful for, it means that I can't always get back to every single one of you. I can't give you the personal individualized advice that I would love to be able to give. But it doesn't mean that these requests and, you know, when you guys share these stories with me, it doesn't go unnoticed. So today I thought, why not dedicate a whole episode to answering some of those dilemmas, to answering some of the questions that you guys have been asking me all year about your own lives and also getting to hear your voices on the show, of course. So I asked you all to send in your biggest dilemmas that you are facing right now, the biggest problems that you're encountering, the places where you feel stuck, the places where
你知道，拥有一个庞大的社区，对此我非常感激，这意味着我无法总是回复你们每一个人。我无法给你我非常想给的那种个性化的建议。但这并不意味着这些请求，以及，你知道的，当你和我说起这些故事时，并不是石沉大海的。所以今天我想，为什么不专门做一期节目来解答其中一些困惑，来回答你们这一整年一直在问我的关于你们自己生活的问题，当然，还能在节目中听到你们的声音。所以我请大家发送你们目前面临的最大困惑，你们遇到的最大的问题，你们感到卡壳的地方，
you feel behind, to send in voice notes, detailing exactly what it is you're going through. And I'm going to answer them. I'm going to give you all of my advice, the advice that I would give my best friends, the advice that I would give you if we were friends and meeting a person over coffee. So I really, really hope that you enjoy this episode. And I want to give a huge shout out to this, everyone who sent in a voice message, first of all. There were just so many of them. So we did listen to them all and they were, all of you were so eloquent, first of all, so intelligent. And all the dilemmas were things that I was like, wow, we've all got a lot on our plate. So thank you so much for sending them through. I chose
你们觉得落后于人的地方，发送语音便签，详细说明你们到底在经历什么。我会回答这些问题。我会给你们我所有的建议，如果我的挚友们遇到这种情况我会给他们的建议，如果我们是朋友，在咖啡馆见面时我会给你的建议。所以我真的、真的很希望你们会喜欢这一期节目。首先，我要向所有发送语音留言的人致以诚挚的谢意。数量实在是太多了。所以我们都听了，而且它们——首先，你们所有人都表达得那么流畅，那么聪明。所有的困惑都是那种让我觉得“哇，我们每个人都有很多事情要处理”的事情。所以非常感谢你们发来这些内容。我挑选了
seven. Seven of the dilemmas that I felt would resonate with you all the most, but also which resonated with me. So I hope that you enjoy this episode and specifically hearing from people just like you are the listeners of the show. Without further ado, I say we get into this special limited edition, special version of the podcast, the listener episode of 2024. Let's get into it. I'm just going to get right into it and play one of the very first voice notes that we received. First off, I love you and your podcast and everything that you do for the community. Second, I've been dating this guy for about seven, eight months, and sometimes I feel like I'm asking a lot from him emotionally, and he does it, but it still gives me a lot of anxiety to
七个。我认为最能引起你们共鸣，同时也最能引发我共鸣的七个困惑。所以我希望你们会喜欢这一期节目，特别是听到那些和你们一样——节目听众的声音。废话不多说，让我们进入这期特别的限量版、特别版播客，2024 年听众特辑。我们开始吧。我这就直奔主题，播放我们收到的第一条语音便签。首先，我爱你，爱你的播客，以及你为社区所做的一切。其次，我和这个男生大约交往了七、八个月了，有时我觉得自己在情感上对他的要求有点多，他确实做到了，但要求时仍然会给我带来很大的焦虑。
ask. How would you cope with that? Thank you so much for your question. And also, I'm so glad that you are loving the show that honestly makes me feel very, very happy. I think this is a hard dilemma, right? Communicating our emotions is always difficult because A, sometimes we feel like with the right person we shouldn't have to. B, sometimes we feel like we are over asking. And C, you know, it's never easy being vulnerable, even with people that we really, really care about. I think my interpretation of your dilemma is that you feel bad for having to ask and you feel like you're putting a lot on his plate, but also you feel like maybe you shouldn't have to. I think that having to ask what you want from someone emotionally or having to maybe really highlight
你会如何应对这种情况？非常感谢你的提问。同时，我也很高兴你喜欢这个节目，这真的让我感到非常、非常开心。我认为这是一个艰难的困惑，对吧？表达我们的情感总是困难的，因为 A，有时我们觉得和对的人在一起，我们本不该如此。B，有时我们觉得我们的要求过分了。C，你知道的，展露脆弱从来都不是一件容易的事，哪怕是对那些我们非常、非常关心的人。我认为我对你困惑的解读是，你因为不得不开口而感到内疚，觉得你给他增加了很大的负担，但同时也觉得你或许本不觉得应该去要求。我认为不得不开口向某人表达你在情感上的需求，或者不得不向他们真正强调
to them what you need from them when you need them, when you need it from them, that's probably a better way of saying it. I actually think that's a really, really healthy part of a relationship. And it can feel exhausting to have to do it over and over again. and I do think that it does get to a point where perhaps you need to be considering whether someone is actually learning from your moments of vulnerability and learning from the times that you are communicating. But being seven to eight months into a relationship, you are still firmly in the learning phase of the relationship. Some people call it the honeymoon phase, right? But I call it
当你需要时，你需要他们为你做什么，当你需要他们的时候，换个更好的说法，这可能是一个更好的表达方式。其实我认为这是恋爱中一个非常、非常健康的组成部分。而且不得不一次又一次地这样做确实会让人感到精疲力竭。而且我确实认为，在某种程度上，你可能需要考虑某人是否真的在从你的脆弱时刻中学习，在从你进行沟通的时刻中学习。但是在恋爱七到八个月的时候，你们其实仍然牢牢地处在了解彼此的阶段。有些人称之为蜜月期，对吧？但我称之为
the learning phase. This is when you are really getting to know the other person. And of course, you're getting to know all the really, really fun stuff, right? Like, oh, what do your parents do for a living? That's not very fun. I don't know why that's the first thing that came to my mind. But, you know, when was the first time you broke an arm? And what did you want to be when you were a kid? And what's your biggest ambition? And where do you want to travel? You're learning all those, like, factoid about them or the trivia. And then you're also learning the deeper stuff, the deeper stuff, like their insecurities, like the times they've been hurt. And like how they need you to show up for them emotionally. So right now I actually think that it's quite normal for you to have to communicate and ask,
了解阶段。这个时候你正在真正地了解另一个人。当然，你会了解到所有非常、非常有趣的事情，对吧？比如，哦，你父母是做什么工作的？那其实没那么有趣。我不知道为什么那是脑子里蹦出来的第一件事。但是，比如说，你第一次骨折是什么时候？你小时候想成为什么样的人？你最大的抱负是什么？你想去哪里旅行？你正在了解他们所有的这些琐事或八卦。然后你也会了解更深层的东西，更深层的东西，比如他们的不安全感，他们受过创伤的经历，以及他们需要你如何在情感上支持他们。所以现在我其实觉得你需要沟通和要求是很正常的，
and I don't want you to feel like you're being a burden for doing that. In fact, the right person, that should be something that they want to know. That should be something that they are actually interested in learning from you because it means that they can show up for you in the future. And they can continue to make the relationship work by being a good partner. That's really the core part of this, right? So if this is the right person, A, I don't think that they'll mind. I think that hopefully they will continue to want to learn even in five, 10, 20 years, if that's where the relationship takes you. Back to your anxiety about having to ask. I kind of interpreted this two ways. Like, A, I shouldn't have to ask because I shouldn't, he should know, which I think no one ever knows. We kind of covered that
我不希望你因为这样做而觉得自己是个累赘。事实上，对于对的人来说，这应该是他们想要知道的事情。这应该是他们实际上有兴趣从你这里了解的事情，因为这意味着他们将来可以为你提供支持。他们可以通过作为一个好伴侣，让这段关系继续运作下去。这才是最核心的部分，对吧？所以如果这是对的人，A，我觉得他们不会介意。我希望他们甚至在五年、十年、二十年之后，如果这段关系发展到那一步的话，仍然会想要去了解。回到你关于不得不开口的焦虑。我把这解读为两种情况。就像，A，我不应该开口，因为我不应该，他应该懂，而我认为没有人会懂。我们之前讨论过
before. The only way, you know, no one's a mind reader, even people who are soulmates. So it takes a while to start to get a good read on someone else's emotions. But that second component of your anxiety is, I don't want to be a burden, right? And I think that that anxiety really comes from previous instances and previous relationships where you were made to feel like your vulnerability was a weight that someone else didn't want to carry. And that can be in, obviously, a family relationship. Say, for example, you were the child who maybe was ignored, maybe your parents were quite emotionally withdrawn, so big displays of emotion and vulnerability weren't really accounted for, or maybe it was in a friendship or an early relationship where you would come to someone
这一点。唯一的办法是，没有人会读心术，即使是灵魂伴侣也一样。所以需要一段时间才能开始对另一个人的情绪有很好的感知。但你焦虑的第二个成分是，我不想成为累赘，对吧？我认为这种焦虑实际上源于以往的经历和以往的恋爱关系，在那些关系中，你曾让你觉得你的脆弱是别人不想承担的负担。这显然可以发生在家庭关系中。比如说，假设你是一个可能被忽视的孩子，也许你的父母在情感上相当疏离，所以宏大的情绪表达和脆弱并没有得到真正的回应，或者也许它发生在一段友谊或早期的恋爱关系中，那时你会带着情绪和脆弱去找某人，而他们却不屑一顾。我认为这确实是我们对分享情绪几乎感到内疚和尴尬的很大一部分根源。而这是我们在二十多岁时真正需要抛弃的东西，因为如果我们继续活在那种说“我们作为情绪化的存在本身就是问题”的心态中，实际上，A，我们永远无法真正与其他人建立联系，B，我们是在对自己做极大的伤害。
with your emotions and with your vulnerability and they would be dismissive. I think that that is really a big origin for a lot of our almost guilt and embarrassment for sharing our emotions. And that's something that we really have to unlearn in our 20s, because if we continue to live in that space in our mind that says, we are the problem for being emotional beings, we actually, A, never really get to connect with anyone else, and B, we do ourselves a huge disservice.
摆脱这种心态的一部分，其实就是去做那件感觉最难的事情，那就是展露脆弱，保持诚实。从本质上讲，就是向其他人敞开心扉，寻求帮助，并且在他们没有以正确的方式回应时，不让自己感到被拒绝，相反，要意识到也许那个人并不适合你，同时也知道对的人根本不会觉得这是个负担。所以这实际上是违背你可能被教导、被学习或看到的、教你把这些东西藏起来的一切，而是选择彻底地反其道而行之，让它变得非常、非常明显。所以这是一个非常普遍的
Part of unlearning that is actually doing the thing that feels the hardest, which is just being vulnerable and being honest. and essentially giving our emotions to other people asking for help and not allowing ourselves to feel rejected if they don't respond the proper way, instead knowing that maybe that person isn't right for you, but also knowing that the right person will not feel burdened by that at all. So it's really about going against everything that perhaps you've been taught or you've learnt or you've seen that says hide these things away and choosing to, very radically do the absolute opposite and make it very, very visible. So it's a very common
情况。我认为人们在恋爱初期都会发现自己处于这种境地。你知道，什么是太多了？什么是太情绪化了？什么是太喧闹了？我能分享什么？我不能分享什么？我最大的建议是，分享你脑海中正在发生的任何事情，让人去爱你的。给他们一个照顾你的机会，并在他们学着适应你的独特状态和你看待世界的独特方式时，表现出足够的优雅和包容。所以祝你的恋爱顺利。我很高兴他做到了，我认为这是一个了不起的迹象，并祝你们充满爱与幸福。好的，让我们进入下一个问题。嗨，所以这背后有一点背景故事。我大学主修艺术，我是一名版画家。我从
situation. I think people find themselves in in the early stages of relationship. You know, what is too much? What is too emotional? What is too loud? What can I share? What can I share? My biggest piece of advice is to share whatever is going on in your mind, to let people love you. give them the gift of getting to care for you, and also being quite graceful and forgiving as they learn to adapt to your unique states and your unique way of seeing the world. So good luck in your relationship. I like that he does it. I think that that's an amazing sign and just wishing you lots of lots of love and happiness. All right, let's move on to our next question. Hi, so there's a little bit of backstory to this. I went to college for art and I am a printmaker. I graduated from
2022年从艺术学校毕业，从那以后我一直在做不同的工作，大约四个月前，在经历了一年左右的培训后，我开始做发型师。所以在开始做美发之前，我没有从事创意类的工作，我还能有更多的时间在业余时间做我的艺术创作，但现在我从事创意领域的工作，我真的不再有想去做版画的冲动了。我会有一些我想创作的东西的点子，我会想，哦，这会超级酷。让我把它记下来。然后有时我会坐下来想，好吧，今天我要开始创作了。我要创作艺术。我只能坚持大约 30 分钟，然后我就对这项活动感到如此厌烦，再也没有灵感了。我正试图不强迫自己去做，因为那样的话我会对这项活动感到
art school in 2022 and I've been working different jobs since then and about four months ago I started working as a hairstylist after like a year of a training. So before the I started doing hair, I like didn't have a creative job and I was still able to do my art on the side a little bit more, but now that I'm working in a creative field, I really don't have the urge to work on my printmaking anymore. I will have ideas for like stuff I want to make and I'll think, oh, this would be super cool. Let me write it down. And then sometimes I'll like sit down and be like, okay, today I'm doing it. I'm working on art. And I'll only make it like 30 minutes before I'm just so like bored of the activity and not inspired anymore. And I'm trying to not force myself to do it because then I just
更加怨恨。但是，是的，如果你有什么建议或懂任何心理学知识能帮我走出这个小低谷，我将非常感激。谢谢。我喜欢你的节目。这是一个很好的问题。另外，你的声音。真的是太可爱了。我就是喜欢你的声音。我听到这个声音对她说，我心想她听起来好有趣、好活泼、好可爱。
feel even more resentment from the activity. But yeah, I'd love to hear if you have any advice or know any psychology that could, you know, help me get out of this little rut. I'm in. Thank you. I love your show. This is such a great question. Also, your voice is. is just so cute. Like I just love the tone of your voice. I like heard this voice to her and I was like, she sounds so like fun and peppy and lovely.
但回到你的问题，我敢拿大笔赌注打赌，你所经历的正是职业倦怠。我经历过。我做过。我穿过这件 T 恤。在版画、美发等创意领域工作，如果你是一名艺术家、舞蹈家、音乐家，
But back to your question, I would bet good money on the fact that what you were experiencing is creative burnout. And I have been there. I have done that. I have got the T-shirt. Working in a creative space with printmaking, with hairdressing, if you're an artist, if you're a dancer, if you're a musician,
这是令人筋疲力尽的，因为你的创造力不仅仅源于你身体能做的事情。它源于你所处的情感状态、身体感受、心理状态、你对生活的感受。这就是为什么这是一份如此艰难的职业，因为你真的必须全身心投入，完全沉浸，完全拥抱你的本质。
it is exhausting because your creativity is derived from so much more than just what you can physically do. It's derived from where you're at emotionally, how you feel physically, how you feel mentally, how you feel about your life. And that is why it is such a hard career to have because you really do have to be almost fully in it, fully immersed, fully embracing your meat. in order to feel inspired and to feel like you want to make something. I think the big turning point for you was probably starting the hairdressing job, right? That is also equally quite a demanding job creatively and visually and aesthetically and also
才能获得灵感，才能感觉自己想创作点什么。我想对你来说，转折点可能就是开始做美发工作吧？这也是一份在创意、视觉、美学以及
time-wise. I think perhaps a lot of the energy that you had previously reserved for printmaking is now being given to hairdressing. This thing is taking up a bigger slice of your brain. It's taking up more of the pie and all the energy that you previously and all the inspiration as well and all of the, perhaps even the emotional resources that you used to devote to printmaking into this creative form of expression is kind of being dominated by hairdressing in the way that you're making money. That is also a really common and difficult dilemma with anyone who works in a creative space. It's the kind of toss up between, I need to make money from this, but also I need to be inspired. And being inspired
时间上同样要求很高的工作。我想，以前你可能留给版画的很多精力现在都给了美发。这件事占据了你大脑更大的一块。它占去了更多的大饼，而你以前用来做版画、投入到这种创意表达形式中的所有精力、所有的灵感、甚至可能是所有的情感资源，现在都被美发所主导，以这种你能赚钱的方式。这也是任何在创意领域工作的人都会遇到的一个非常普遍且困难的困惑。这就好比是一种权衡：我需要从中赚钱，但我也需要有灵感。而获得灵感
requires rest and it requires introspection and it requires time devoted to my craft. It's very hard to find a way that you can have both, that you can get paid to make art and still love it. And so a lot of people do seek alternatives and do seek other careers and, you know, that aren't their primary medium to make money. And I think that that's really explaining what you're going through right now. So creative burnout. That's really what we're getting at. What I want you to focus on, and you're already doing this, is not creating. Actually, what I want you to focus on is just being inspired. the next six months, all I want you to do is focus on finding things that inspire you. And it doesn't even have to do with printmaking, things that inspire joy, stories that pop into
需要休息，需要内省，需要把时间投入到你的手艺中。要找到一种既能通过艺术赚钱又能保持热爱的方法是非常困难的。所以很多人都在寻找替代方案，寻找其他的职业，你知道的，而不是把他们的主要媒介作为赚钱的手段。我想这确实解释了你现在正在经历的事情。所以是创意倦怠。这正是我们所讨论的。我想让你关注的，而且你已经在这样做了，就是不要去创作。实际上，我只想让你关注一件事：寻找灵感。接下来的六个月里，我希望你关注的全部事情就是寻找能给你灵感的事物。甚至不必与版画有关，寻找能带来快乐的事物，那些突然闪现在
your mind that you're like, wow, that's kind of funny. Little things that you see on the street that make you laugh or make you think. A beautiful sunset, a beautiful autumn tree, I don't know, a beautiful steam rising from your coffee. be inspired. That is what you're in the business of. Because being inspired takes up a lot less energy than being physically creative and having to put pen to paper or, I guess, scuple to linoleum. I don't really know how printmaking works, really. But I want that to be your primary gore right now to just be inspired. What I tend to find is that when we focus on inspiration, our desire to create gets bigger and bigger and bigger because we're putting more fuel on the fire,
你脑海中让你觉得“哇，这挺有意思”的故事。你在街上看到的让你发笑或引人思考的小事。美丽的日落，美丽的秋树，我不知道，从咖啡中升起的袅袅热气。寻找灵感。这就是你现在要经营的业务。因为寻找灵感比进行体力上的创作、不得不拿起笔（或者我想是雕刻刀对准油毡板——我其实不太清楚版画是怎么制作的）要消耗少得多的能量。但我希望这成为你目前的主要目标，去寻找灵感。我往往发现，当我们专注于灵感时，我们创作的欲望会越来越强烈，因为我们在往火堆里添更多的燃料，
right? We have more things that we want to make into something physical, that we want to be able to show people. And so the more creative and inspirational and motivational wood that you stack up, the more things that you see, I think begins to push you and begins to almost relight the fire that makes you want to create. So what's going to eventually happen, and this is what's happened to me before, is that when I start looking for inspiration, rather than putting pressure on myself to actually make something, eventually I get to a tipping point where I'm like, something comes along that I
对吧？我们有更多想要变成实体、想要展示给别人的东西。所以你堆积的越多创意、灵感和动力的木柴，你看到的东西越多，我想就会开始推动你，并开始重新点燃让你想要创作的火花。所以最终会发生的事情是——这也是我以前经历过的——当我开始寻找灵感，而不是给自己施加压力去实际制作点什么时，最终我会达到一个临界点，某个契机出现了，那个契机是我
have trained myself to look for that really, like, sets a spark in me, or eventually I'm just like, I just need to make something that all of that energy that I've been saving up through inspiration comes crashing down and suddenly like I'm awakened again and I'm alive again and I want to be making stuff. I'll also say sometimes these things come and go, right? Sometimes people do, you know, there's authors who don't write for decades at a time. There are artists who don't make any new works for years. There are songwriters who, you know, stop making music for two decades and then they come back to their craft because something calls them back. So maybe you're just in a period of waiting at the moment. You're just in a period of having different priorities of not feeling as
训练自己去寻找的，它真正地在我的内心中点燃了火花，或者最终我只是觉得：我只需要创作点什么，我通过灵感积蓄下来的所有能量都会倾泻而出，突然间我又被唤醒了，我又充满了活力，我想开始创作了。我也要说，有时这些东西来来去去，对吧？有时人们会——你知道的，有些作家会有几十年的时间不写作。有些艺术家会有好几年不创作任何新作品。有些词曲作者，你知道的，会停止创作音乐二十年，然后又重操旧业，因为某种召唤让他们回去了。所以也许你现在只是处于一段等待期。你正处于拥有不同优先级、不再感到那么
attached and in love with what you have trained to do. And that is okay. It doesn't mean that you've lost it forever. The one thing I've learned about creativity is it doesn't like to be forced. It does not like to be a chore and it most certainly does not like to be something that you have to squeeze out of yourself. it should flow, it should come naturally. And if that's not the case right now, maybe you need to retreat backwards a little bit and just let it rest. And there's nothing wrong with doing that. You won't lose it. You won't, you know, leave it and never return. And even if you do, maybe that's a good thing. Maybe you're making space for something else. So to summarize what I'm saying, search for inspiration. Don't force yourself to create because that is the creativity hates being
依恋并热爱你所学手艺的时期。这没关系。这并不意味着你永远失去了它。关于创造力，我学到的一件事是，它不喜欢被强迫。它不喜欢成为一种杂务，更绝对不喜欢成为一种必须从你身上榨取出来的东西。它应该顺其自然，应该自然而然地流露。如果现在情况并非如此，也许你需要稍微退后一步，让它休息一下。这样做并没有错。你不会失去它。你不会，你知道的，把它抛在一边就再也不回头了。即使你真的这么做了，也许这也是一件好事。也许你正在为其他事情腾出空间。所以总结一下我的话，去寻找灵感。不要强迫自己去创作，因为那是——创造力讨厌被
forced. It's never a good sign. And give yourself some space to explore other things and to just let your creativity and to let your skills just sit for a while, marinate, just have a little bit of a break. But yeah, I'm really, really rooting for you. And it's something that I've experienced before and have come at the other side. So you're not going to lose it. Don't worry. And maybe this is a good time to see that your identity is made of more, could be made of more. All right, we're going to take a short break and then we will return to hear more of your 20-something dilemmas. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness,
强迫。这绝不是一个好兆头。给自己留出一些空间去探索其他事情，让你的创造力和技能闲置一段时间，让它们沉淀，稍微休息一下。但是，是的，我真的、真的很支持你。这是我以前经历过并且已经走出来的事情。所以你不会失去它的。别担心。也许这是一个好时机，让你发现你的身份可以由更多、更丰富的东西组成。好吧，我们稍作休息，然后回来听取更多你们二十多岁的困惑。请继续收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧性、体能的科学，
and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with you. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person.
以及在我们的奇异现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与你们对话。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上担心的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
收听《2%》。即 TWO%，可在 I-Hart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击了小吉姆的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小吉姆有什么鬼关系？好吧，你可以在《回首过往》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here. unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份。剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈 80 年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊当时的快克，但只是想让你们知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black. people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以。然后你接着那句话说。是的。我认为对于黑。人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方，收听《回首过往》。
your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it
欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难成长的法则》，我是主持人兼你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐。
and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro
而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们盯着生活记分牌，生活变成了胜负。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这里做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
absolutely and that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
绝对是的，那是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《艰难成长的法则》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《艰难成长的法则》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这份特定的测试，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的脑子炸裂了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. We are back with more listener dilemmas. Let's hear from this next person.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。我们带着更多听众的困惑回来了。让我们听听下一位朋友的声音。
Hi, Gemma. I'm in my mental eight 20s. and I just can't help but feeling like I have to choose between owning a house or continuing to travel. My husband and I both have really good paying jobs with college degrees, and I still feel like we're not doing as well as we should be. We have spent quite a bit of time and money traveling, which I absolutely don't regret, but in doing so, we have made sacrifices. We live in the U.S. and have lived in a one-bedroom apartment in the Midwest for about three years, and rent just keeps going up.
嗨，杰玛。我处于二十岁出头的中段。我就是忍不住觉得，我必须在买房和继续旅行之间做出选择。我和我丈夫都有着大学学历的高薪工作，但我仍然觉得我们过得没有想象中那么好。我们花了不少时间和金钱去旅行，对此我绝对不后悔，但在这样做的同时，我们也做出了牺牲。我们住在美国，在中西部的一套一卧室公寓里住了大约三年，房租一直在上涨。
But I'm anxious because I feel like once we buy a house, our ability to travel will significantly decrease. I can't help but feeling like, although we should be well off, we'll have to give up travel for a house or give up a house to continue to travel. All of my friends are in the same boat, too. My parents and my husband's parents don't seem to understand why we still don't have a house, and I just get discouraged every time I try and explain how different times are from when they bought their first house. Is it even possible to travel and own a house successfully in your 20s, or am I just setting unrealistic expectations? Oh my goodness. What a big question. And you know what? At face value, it looks like it's about, you know, home ownership versus travel, but it's about so much more than that. You already mentioned one of those things, your parents and your husband's parents, not understanding that the priorities of this generation are a whole lot different. No longer is property ownership and starting a family really young and just slowly going up the corporate career ladder what most people want. We are such a privileged generation where we see opportunities out there. We see the opportunity to travel that's something a lot of us
但我感到焦虑，因为我觉得一旦我们买了一栋房子，我们旅行的能力就会大大下降。我忍不住觉得，尽管我们应该算得上生活优渥，但我们要么得为了买房而放弃旅行，要么得为了继续旅行而放弃买房。我所有的朋友也都处于同样的处境。我的父母和我丈夫的父母似乎不明白为什么我们现在还没有房子，每当我试图解释现在的时代和他们买第一套房子的时代有多么不同时，我都会感到沮丧。二十多岁时既去旅行又能成功买房，这真的可能吗，还是说我只是设定了不切实际的期望？天哪。多大的一个问题啊。你知道吗？表面上看，这似乎是关于，你知道的，拥有住房与旅行的选择，但这关乎更多的事情。你已经提到了其中一件事，你的父母和你丈夫的父母，他们不理解这一代人的首要任务已经大不相同了。拥有房产和很年轻就组建家庭，然后慢慢在职场阶层中往上爬，不再是大多数人真正想要的了。我们是如此幸运的一代，我们看到了外面的机遇。我们看到了旅行的机会，这是我们很多人都在拥抱的事情，特别是在很多方面，因为诸如，你知道的，像拥有住房这样的传统成功标志根本不可能实现。它们看起来似乎不再那么可行了。而且感觉它们让我们付出的不仅仅是金钱。
are embracing, especially in many ways because things like, you know, traditional markers of success like home ownership are just not possible. They just don't seem as doable anymore. And it feels like they cost us a lot more than the money. they also cost us experiences and they cost us flexibility and they cost us a life that we would want to live. I am in the same boat. I'm going to be completely honest. I don't know anyone around me who is thinking about homeownership. Obviously I live in Sydney, which is like the second most expensive city in the world. But if you live in any large city, I think it's something that really comes up. Why would I continue to potentially save for a house that I might be able to buy?
它们还让我们失去了经历，失去了灵活性，失去了我们想要过的生活。我也处于同样的处境。老实说，我并不认识周围有谁在考虑买房。显然我住在悉尼，这是世界上房价第二贵的城市。但如果你住在任何大城市，我想这确实是一个经常出现的问题。为什么我要继续为一套我可能买得起的房子攒钱？
that's just going to put me in so much debt. I might not even be able to do it and I'm going to have to give up a life that I actually really, really want. So this is how I think you should reframe this question in your mind. Why do you want a house? Genuine question. I know you mentioned that your rent is increasing. It's likely that, you know, your house might be just as expensive, but is it because you want to put money towards something you own. Why do you want it? Is it because it's what everyone has told you you need to have by a certain time? Is that why you want the house? Is it because the house and having a house and getting to decorate it and having a place that's your own? Is that actually your dream? Is it for the financial stability of not having to pay rent? I want you to really think about
这只会让我背负沉重的债务。我甚至可能买不起，而且我将不得不放弃我真正、真正想要的生活。所以我认为你应该在脑海中这样重新构建这个问题：你为什么要买房？这是一个真诚的问题。我知道你提到过你们的房租在上涨。很可能，你知道，你们的房子可能也同样昂贵，但这是因为你想把钱存进你拥有的东西里吗？你为什么想要它？是因为这是每个人都告诉你你在某个时间点必须拥有的东西吗？这就是你想要房子的原因吗？是因为房子、拥有房子并有机会装饰它、拥有一个属于你自己的地方？这真的是你的梦想吗？是为了免交房租的财务稳定性吗？我想让你认真想想
why you really want to own a property and whether that why is the biggest why in your life right now. Is the reason you want to buy a property the most important thing to you? Is financial stability the most important thing to you? Is having a stable place to live the most important thing to you? Or is it travel? Is it still being in this flexible, adaptable, adaptable error of your life? Is it still having the opportunity to put the money that you would,
为什么你真的想拥有房产，以及这个“为什么”是不是你生活中目前最大的“为什么”。你想要买房的原因对你来说是最重要的事吗？财务稳定对你来说是最重要的事吗？拥有一个稳定的居住地对你来说是最重要的事吗？还是说，旅行才是？你是否仍然处于这个灵活、适应性强的人生阶段？你是否仍然有机会把你
otherwise put towards a property, towards new experiences. So I really want you to think, what are your motivations? Because, you know, the opportunity to buy a house, that is always going to be there in some form or another. Yes, your financial situation might change, but I don't think that travel will always be there. You know, when you are 70, 80, 90, you are maybe going to look back at this time in your life and think, gosh, why did we feel so pressured to do this traditional thing and to follow this blueprint? And we gave up something that we weren't done with yet. We weren't done with the travel. We weren't done with this freedom and this, you know, period of our life. There are also, of course, alternatives. And obviously I'm not going to give you
原本要投入到房产中的钱，投入到新的经历中去。所以我真的很想让你想想，你的动机是什么？因为，你知道，买房的机会，它总会以这样或那样的形式存在。是的，你的财务状况可能会改变，但我不认为旅行会一直存在。你知道的，当你七十、八十、九十岁时，你可能会回顾人生的这段时光，心想，天哪，为什么我们当时会感受到这么大的压力去做这种传统的事情，去遵循这个蓝图？而我们却放弃了一些我们还没享受够的东西。我们还没享受够旅行。我们还没享受够这种自由，以及这段，你知道的，人生的阶段。当然，还有其他的选择。显然我不会给你
any financial advice, but you could buy somewhere else cheaper and then you could keep traveling, or you could use, you know, you could buy a property and then use it as a rental for the next two years and then maybe even live with your parents so that you could still have that little nest egg, that house, and still be able to travel. Not that I'm really like promoting becoming a landlord, but you know what I mean? Like there are options that you could do both. You could also move out of your current apartment and move somewhere perhaps a little bit more regional. I think you said you lived in New York, like you could move upstate so that you could do travel around those parts whilst still paying less rent.
任何财务建议，但你可以去其他地方买便宜一点的房子，然后继续旅行，或者你可以利用，你知道的，你可以买下一处房产，然后在接下来的两年里把它出租，甚至可能和你的父母住在一起，这样你既能拥有那笔小小的储蓄、那栋房子，又能继续旅行。倒不是说我真的在鼓励当房东，但你知道我的意思吗？也就是说，你可以有一些选项来两全其美。你也可以搬出目前的公寓，搬到一个可能更偏远一点的地方。我想你说过你住在纽约，比如你可以搬到州北部，这样你既可以在那些地方附近旅行，同时房租还能付得少一点。
So there are alternatives, but I really think that you need to consider why it is you want to buy a house and whether that is the most important thing to you right now. Whether buying a house is going to really align with the priorities of this chapter in your life, more so than other alternatives and then go from there. But yeah, you're definitely not alone in that one. I have just kind of completely given up the prospect, to be completely honest. I'm like, why not have fun? And some people might call that doom spending and might say that that's poor financial
所以确实有其他选择，但我真的认为你需要好好想想，你究竟为什么想买房，这现在对你来说是不是最重要的事情。买房是不是真的能和你人生这个阶段的优先级相契合，比起其他选择是不是更重要，然后以此做决定。不过说真的，你绝对不是一个人。说实话，我其实已经彻底放弃这个念头了。我的心态是，为什么不及时行乐呢？有些人可能会把这叫做“末日消费”，或者说这是理财观念差，又或者说我做了错误的选择。但我觉得归根结底，我们这一代人想要拥有父母辈以及祖辈那样买房的机会，同时还能过上我们想要的小资生活，这种可能性实在是太低了。所以作为新一代，我们的优先级正在改变，但这并不意味着这些优先级是错的。祝你好运。随时向我汇报。在Instagram上私信我。我很想知道你最后到底怎么做了。我真的特别关心。好了，让我们来听听另一位可爱听众提出的问题。大家好。我20多岁时的困惑是，我面对众多的选择和发展方向时，感到了深深的焦虑。
literacy or that I'm making the wrong choices. But I think at the end of the day, it's just so implausible that this generation, all of us could have the same opportunities that our parents and their parents had to buy property and to then still be able to have the little luxuries that we want. So as a generation, our priorities are changing and that doesn't mean that those priorities are wrong. So best of luck. Keep me updated. D.m me on Instagram. I want to know what you end up doing. I'm very invested. All right. Let's jump into another question from one of you, lovely, lovely listeners. Hi there. So my 20 something's dilemma is that I feel overwhelmed by the amount of options.
或者说我可以去追求的方向。我感到焦虑，是因为我害怕自己选错。我害怕选错方向，结果在那里白白浪费了我的潜力。我还害怕，不仅会在那里浪费潜力，还会浪费时间——就好像所有事情都必须赶快完成一样。感觉每件事都有个时间表，哪怕其实并没有，但很多时候感觉就是这样。这就是我最终恐惧的事情：选错了追求的方向，浪费了潜力与时间，却没有找到实现价值的满足感。关于这个困惑，我首先想说的是
or directions that I can choose to pursue. I feel overwhelmed because I'm scared I don't choose the correct one. I'm scared I choose the wrong one and I end up wasting my potential there. And I'm also scared that not only do I end up wasting my potential there, I end up wasting time there that like everything feels like it needs to get done in a rush. It feels like everything has a timeline, even though it doesn't, it feels like it a lot of the times. And that's what I'm ultimately scared of choosing the wrong, like, pursuit and wasting my potential and my time and not feeling fulfilled. The first thing I want to say to this dilemma is that
我敢说我们当中90%、95%，甚至100%的人都有着一模一样的感受。我想对你说的是：我真心觉得，20多岁是用来探索的，而30多岁甚至40多岁才是用来做决定的。所以，我明白你现在觉得自己必须做出许多重大而关键的决定，并且必须坚守这些决定、对它们忠诚，但实际情况完全不是这样的。我觉得哪怕是在这个十年里，我20岁刚出头时的状态，
I'm assuming 90, 95, maybe even 100% of us are feeling the exact same way. What I want to tell you is this. I really think that your 20s are for exploring and then your 30s and even your 40s are for deciding. So I know it feels like you need to make a lot of really big, important decisions right now and you need to stay with those decisions and be loyal to those decisions. that is totally not the case. I think that even within this decade, how I begun my 20s,
跟我20岁刚到中段时做的事情截然不同，又跟我在20多岁中期正在做的事情大不相同，对吧？生活是充满流动性的，事情总在变化。所以我觉得你真正纠结的，其实是你知道自己正站在起跑线上，而前方有无数的分支在延伸，
was so different to what I was doing in like my mid, early mid-20s to what I'm doing in my mid-20s, right? There is fluidity there. Things do change. And so I think what you're really struggling with, though, is you know, you're at this starting line and there is all these branches stemming out,
从你目前所在的地方向外延伸。这就是西尔维娅·普拉斯经典的“无花果树”隐喻。每一根树枝的尽头，都挂着一颗美丽的果实。你知道的，你可以成为一名医生。你可以成为一位母亲。你可以成为一名律师。你可以去旅行。你可以成为一名音乐家。
stemming out from where you are. And it's the classic Sylvia Plath, fig tree analogy. At the end of every branch is this beautiful piece of fruit. You know, you could be a doctor. You could be a mother. You could be a lawyer. You could be traveling. You could be a musician.
你可以创业。你可以重返校园。有成百万种不同的人生选择。而且每一种听起来都同样诱人。你不知道该选哪一个。感觉好像你只能选一个。但实际上你什么都能做到。只是你无法同时做到所有事情。所以，选择此刻让你感觉最好的那条路吧，同时也要知道，你是可以改变的。我真正想强调的是，根本没有所谓的错误
You could start your own business. You could go back to school. There is a million different alternative lives. And every one of them feels just as appealing. And you don't know which one to choose. And it feels like you can only choose one. you can actually do it all. You just can't do it all at once. So choose whichever path feels best to you right now, knowing that you can change. And what I really want to impress is that there is no such thing as a wrong
选择。时间其实并不是你挥霍得起或浪费掉的东西。你知道的，只要你在经历，就谈不上浪费。所以，我真正希望你接下来关注的重点，不是“我想做什么，我想取得什么成就，我想经历什么？”因为这正是你20多岁时应该做的事。“我到底想在生活中看到什么、感受到什么、听到什么、做些什么？”然后，选择一条感觉最能带你接近那个目标的道路。事情是这样的，并没有哪一条路是绝对正确的。我认为我们经常左右为难的另一件事——在刚才那道问题里也很明显——就是在做那些传统、常规、别人对我们的期望所要求的事情，和做那些也许我们更想做、
choice. Time is actually not something that you can waste. You know, it's not a waste if you're having an experience. And so what I really want you to focus on moving forward, is not what do I want to do, what do I want to achieve, what do I want to experience? Because that is what your 20s are about right now. What do I actually want to see, feel here, do with my life? And just choose one pathway that feels like it's going to get you closest to whatever that is. And here's the thing, there is no one right pathway. I think the other thing that we really toss up is, and it really came up with that last question as well is the pool between doing something that is traditional, conventional, expected of us, and doing something that maybe we want to do more
没那么传统、更自由灵活、可能也更有风险和让人害怕的事情之间拉扯，究竟哪一种对我们的吸引力最大。你必须顺从你的直觉，听从你的内心。我觉得，20多岁最大的特权就在于你可以犯错，而且时间一点也没有被浪费。把这十年当作你的“实验十年”吧。在步入30岁之前，一切真的都没那么重要，只要你去体验就行了，对吧？只要你在做一件你在乎的事情，它就能把你引向一条好的道路，哪怕你以后决定改变方向也无所谓。我拿我自己目前做的事情来举个例子吧。我20岁刚出头的时候，对想做什么完全没有头绪，我也处在你的
that's less traditional and more free and flexible and that might be a little bit more risky and scary, which one of those things appeals to us the most. You have to go with your gut and you have to go with your heart. I think especially the privilege of your 20s is that you can make mistakes and that, you know, time is not wasted at all. Think of this as like your experimental decade. You know, it doesn't really matter until you start your 30s and you have experiences, right? As long as you are doing something that you care about, that is going to put you on a good path, even if you decide that you want to change later on. And I'll give you the example of what I'm doing right now. I started out my 20s having absolutely no idea what I wanted to do and I was in your
位置上。我想我当时的脑回路大概和你一模一样：我怎么知道？我怎么能确定？我怎么才能把这事做好？我也曾感到非常迷茫，感到非常、非常害怕。所以我只是顺从了当时感觉最好的那条路，坚信自己能从中有所收获，于是我成了一名管理咨询师——虽然没人知道那到底是个啥，因为，你知道的，那是个很奇怪的工作。它就像是一份什么都管的工作。但我确实成了一名管理咨询师。我走上了职场打拼的道路。
position. I think that I probably had the exact same thoughts that you had. How do I know? How can I be sure? How am I going to do this right? And I also just felt really lost and I felt really, felt really, scared. So I just went with the thing that felt best at the time, knowing that I was going to learn something from that and I became a management consultant, which no one knows what that is because, you know, It's a weird job. It's like an everything job. But I became a management consultant. I worked a corporate career.
在20多岁的前两三年里，我心想，好吧，我只要拼命工作就行了。我要狠狠地卷。我要在这家公司里一路升职加农。然后我开办了这个播客。我开始做播客是因为好玩，也是因为我意识到我只是想做点事情。我想做点有创意的事来表达自我。结果突然之间，这件事变得比我的正职工作还要大。
And for, you know, the first two, three years of my 20s, I was like, okay, I'm just going to work really hard. I'm going to hustle really hard. And I'm going to move up the career ladder in this firm. And then I started this podcast. And I started the podcast because it was fun and because I realized that I just wanted to do something. And I wanted to do something creative and to express myself. And then suddenly that became bigger than my corporate job.
现在这就是我的全职工作了。我以前做梦也想不到会有今天。但最重要的一点是，我从未把任何经历视为浪费。我没有把自己死死捆绑在某一条道路上。当有什么东西把我从那条路上拉开时，这一点尤为重要，因为我让自己随波逐流了。所以，选择此刻对你而言最重要的事吧，同时要知道你是可以改变的，时间并未被浪费，每一次经历都会给予你馈赠。直到今天，我依然在运用我在企业工作时学到的东西。
And now this is what I do full time. I never could have expected that. But the thing that was really important was that I didn't see any experience as a waste. And I didn't tie myself down to one path. And that was important when something was pulling me off that path because I let myself float with it. So just choose whatever feels most important to you right now, knowing that you can change, knowing that time is not a waste, knowing that every experience gives you something. And I use the things I learnt in my corporate job still to this day.
如果我没有在更具企业化色彩的世界里有过那段经历，我想我是不会像现在这样快乐、成功，也不会做出正确的商业决策和职业决策的。所以，你一定会没事的。你会做出正确的选择。祝你好运。我觉得我好像总是在最后才说这些。不过在每个问题的最后都是如此，但我真的在所有这些困惑中看到了自己的影子。所以，祝你好运，一切都会好起来的，我向你保证。
And I don't think I would be as happy or as successful or making the right business decisions or making the right career decisions if I hadn't had that previous experience in a more corporate world. So you are going to be okay. You're going to make the right choice. Good luck. I feel like I'm saying this at the end. But at the end of every question, but I do just see myself reflected in all of these. so good luck, it's going to be okay, I promise you.
好了。倒数第二个问题。我们来听听另一位听众的声音。我20多岁的困惑是，眼看着快要30岁了，我在想自己会不会经历同样的模式、同样的经历，并想知道在没有这个播客的情况下，我该如何应对。我注意到这个播客的名字很明显叫《20多岁的心理学》，但你可能会惊讶，我收到了多少关于
All right. Second last question. Let's hear from another listener. My 20s dilemma is almost reaching my 30s and wondering if I will be going through the same patterns, same experiences, and knowing how I can navigate it without this podcast. I nerds that the name of this podcast is obviously the psychology of your 20s, but you would be surprised how many questions I get about. our 30s. Am I going to do the psychology of your 30s or questions or even listeners who are in their 30s? So I think first things first, as much as like the name of this podcast is 20s. I love when people listen who are in their 30s, 40s, 50s. One of the best messages I ever received was from someone
30多岁的问题。大家会问我：“你会做《30多岁的心理学》吗？”甚至还有许多30多岁的听众。所以我觉得首先，尽管这个播客的名字叫“20多岁”，但我特别喜欢30岁、40岁、50岁的人来听。我收到过最棒的私信之一，其实是来自一位
in their 60s actually who was like, oh, it was my situationhip episode and she was like, I just realized that this relationship I had with a man was this and you've given me the words to articulate it. So there is no age limit to this podcast. I also think that it's totally okay if you're still going through the same things in your 30s. Because really what is your 30s other than just a new chapter, right? Is it really that different to go from 29 to 30 than to go from 25 to 26? Like you're only a day older at a time. Only a day older at a time and learning and learning and learning. The other thing I want to say about our 30s is that the other night I had a couple of friends over for like Christmas drinks, holiday drinks, and all of them were in their 30s. And I asked
60多岁的人，她对我说：“哦，那是关于‘暧昧不清（situationship）’的那期节目，我当时突然意识到，我和一个男人的这种关系就是这样的，而你给了我用语言表达出来的能力。”所以这个播客是没有年龄限制的。我也觉得，如果你到了30多岁还在经历同样的事情，那完全没关系。因为说到底，30多岁不也就是人生崭新的一章吗，对吧？从29岁迈向30岁，难道真的比从25岁到26岁有那么大区别吗？你每次其实也就比之前大了一天而已。每天只大一天，然后不断学习、不断学习、不断学习。关于30多岁，我还想说的是，前几天我请了几个朋友来家里喝圣诞酒、节日饮品，她们全都是30多岁。然后我问了
them. I was like, you know, I'm looking at all these people and I admire every single one of your lives. Turning 30 and having the life of any single one of these friends of mine I would be so insanely happy about. And actually what I was like, what's your advice? I was thinking about this question and I was like, what's your advice also because I want that advice. I want my 30s to look like these people I admire. And one of my friends was basically just like, it's really not that different. You just do more for yourself. She was like, all the pressure that you used to face, it seems to almost slide away and you take everything that you've learned from your 20s and you're finally able to apply it. So I think that that's something to be really optimistic about.
她们一个问题。我说：“你知道的，我看着在座的每一个人，我都极其羡慕你们每一个人的生活。如果我到了30岁能拥有你们当中任何一个人的生活，我都会疯狂地感到幸福。”然后实际上我是这样问的：“你们有什么建议吗？”我当时正在思考这个问题，心想：“你们有什么建议呢？我也想要这样的建议。我希望我的30岁能像我所钦佩的这些人一样。”然后我的一个朋友基本上就说：“其实真的没那么大区别。你只是更懂得为自己而活了。”她说，你以前面对的所有压力，似乎都悄然烟消云散了，你把从20多岁学到的一切都融会贯通，终于能够真正运用出来了。所以我觉得这是非常值得乐观的一点。
The other thing I want to say, every single person that I know in their 30s just gets hotter and brighter and more intelligent and more self-assured every single year. Like every single one of them, I'm like, you just get more beautiful and more self-assured. Everything, like, you are just, you are just with age becoming more yourself and more brilliant. And I just think that that actually gives me something to look forward to. I don't know. I'm just actually, I'm pretty excited to turn 30, to be honest, and I know it'll be the end of an error and people always ask me if I'm going to do the psychology of your 30s. I really don't know. Maybe by that point, I'll be ready for something new. But regardless, I know that I'll be excited about it because it is a whole new decade. And how amazing that you turn 30
我还想说的是，我认识的每一个30多岁的人，随着年龄的增长，每年都在变得越来越迷人、越来越耀眼、越来越聪明、越来越自信。真的是每一个人，我都觉得：你们只是变得更美丽、更自信了。每件事……你只是随着年龄的增长，变得越来越像你自己，越来越出色。我觉得这真的给了我一个可以期待的未来。我不知道。说实话，我其实挺期待迈入30岁的，我也知道这将是一个时代的结束，人们总问我以后会不会做《30多岁的心理学》。我真的不知道。也许到了那个时候，我已经准备好迎接新事物了。但无论如何，我知道我会为此感到兴奋，因为这是一个崭新的十年。当你迈入30岁时，这是多么美妙的事啊，
and then you're at the start of a whole new something. It's like you're turning 21 again. You've got this whole new decade and chapter to look forward to. And I always think about this Reese Witherspoon interview and it's very, very random, but it was her interviewing some up-and-coming actress. And the actress goes, oh, I'm 32. And Reese is like, you're such a baby. You are such a baby. She's like, I didn't know anything at 32. I was just beginning. And, you know, she was already a pretty prominent actress. But I think that what that really showed me was that you, You are always young at heart and you're always going to be younger than the next generation. And people always look back at these decades that we put so much gravitas on.
然后你正站在一个全新旅程的起点。这就像你重新21岁一样。你有一整段崭新的十年和崭新的人生篇章去期待。我总是想起瑞茜·威瑟斯彭（Reese Witherspoon）的一次采访，内容非常非常随机，那是她采访一位崭露头角的年轻女演员。那个女演员说：“哦，我32岁了。”瑞茜就说：“你还是个宝宝呢。你简直是个宝宝。”她接着说：“我32岁时什么都不知道呢。我才刚刚开始。”而且要知道，她当时已经是一位相当知名的女演员了。但我觉得，这件事真正向我展示的是：你，你的内心永远年轻，而且你永远比下一代人年轻。人们总会回望那些被我们赋予太多沉重意义的十年，
And in hindsight, they realized that they were still learning and that they still had time and there was still so much to look forward to. It's just that it didn't feel like that then. It felt like the end of something when actually it was the beginning. So congratulations on entering your next decade, the decisive decade, as they call it. And of course, you can still listen to the podcast. You are more than welcome. I think that there is a lot of really amazing stuff in store for you. I can feel it. We're going to take another quick break and then return for our final 20-something dilemma of the listener episode.
而事后回想起来，他们才意识到自己当时仍在学习，时间还很充裕，还有那么多值得期待的事情。只是当时身处其中时感觉不到罢了。那时候感觉就像是什么事情的结束，但实际上它才刚刚开始。所以，祝贺你迈入下一个十年——正如人们所说的，“决定性的十年”。当然，你依然可以继续收听这个播客。这里永远欢迎你。我觉得接下来还有很多非常棒的内容在等着你。我能感觉得到。我们先进行短暂的休息，然后回来解答本期听众问答的最后一个“20多岁困惑”。
Stay tuned. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
请继续收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，带大家拨开充斥在健康产业中那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学迷雾。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引发炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力导致的。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）莉尔·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有个屁的关系？好吧，你可以在播客节目《Look Back at it》中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。其中包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅聊80年代关于“快克（裂纹可卡因）”的节目。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
明确一下，对我和“快克”而言，84年意义重大，不仅仅是因为“快克”。我随时愿意聊聊“快克”的历史，不过先让大家知道这一点。我是说，马克，这已经是我们第二期讨论“快克”了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的脉络了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也摆上台面了。谢谢你帮我把话说完。我觉得对于黑人群真的没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
是的。对我而言，这是美国历史上对黑人群体最重要的年份之一。欢迎收听iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方播出的《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的精彩对话。我说的正是：特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们执着于追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐的过程中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
而我们却还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算“够了”。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要。你究竟是因为害怕才做一个好人？因为这是两种截然不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
完全正确。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正发自内心地去做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）的行列，在我的新播客《迎难而上》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力与人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她谎言中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法律大战，旨在证明真相。埃伦斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改了一次检测。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样遭遇的男子：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我整个人惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. We have one final voice note, one final question from a listener.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《情感陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被正式指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《情感陷阱》播客。我们还有最后一条语音留言，最后一位听众的问题。
and of course I had to end the episode with another Australian, with another Aussie girl who voiced noted in and her dilemma for the podcast. Here she is. Okay, so what has been like coming up for me recently is that so a few months ago, my two-year-long relationship that was a very intense and consisted of a lot of love bombing, ended. And now I've realized that I've sort of pushed all my friends, to the side and that like currently my only friends like only that I would consider my friends
当然，我必须以另一位澳大利亚女孩的语音留言作为本集播客的结尾，她的困惑也是关于这个播客的。她来啦。好的，那么最近发生在我身上的事情是这样的：几个月前，我那段维持了两年、非常浓烈且充满了“爱的轰炸”的恋爱关系结束了。现在我意识到，我好像把所有的朋友都推开了，目前我仅有的朋友——或者说我能算作朋友的
are like my ex-partner's friends, which obviously aren't the most sustainable friendships given the circumstances. So I guess my dilemma is now feeling like I don't really have the friends that I once did before my relationship and I know that's of my own fault. But how do we rekindle those past friendships that I've pushed aside to prioritize my relationship at the time. What a great question. And I'm sorry about your breakup. I'm sure that is a difficult chapter for you. It does get better though and I know you're properly sick of hearing that. But I know it gets better because I've been in your shoes. I've been exactly where you are. I was in a really toxic, terrible relationship when I was 21 and it was just, it cost me so many friendships because I was so
只有我前伴侣的朋友们。考虑到目前的处境，这显然不是最可持续的友谊。所以我想我的困惑在于，现在觉得自己好像没有了恋爱前那种真正属于自己的朋友，我知道这其实是我自己的错。但是，我们该如何重燃那些过去被我为了优先照顾恋爱关系而推到一边去的友谊呢？这是一个多么棒的问题啊。我很遗憾听到你分手了。我相信这对你来说是一个艰难的阶段。不过情况会好转的，我知道你大概已经厌烦听到这句话了。但我知道情况会变好，因为我曾走过你的老路。我经历过你现在所处的一切。我21岁时曾经历过一段非常糟糕、有毒的感情，那段感情让我失去了太多的友谊，因为我把太多的精力
invested in him and I was so enamored with him and it was just not a very healthy dynamic and he made me equally anxious and excited and that kept me really wrapped around his finger. And because of how enraptured I was with him, it meant that I found any excuse to be friends with his friends. And just naturally, I spent so much time with them and at their house that I fell into those friendships really, really easily. Because of course, it's convenient, they're around, they're probably really nice people. When the relationship inevitably ended, I, of course, felt devastated and heartbroken by the fact that I wasn't with this person anymore, but also I felt an additional form of social pain that came from losing those friendships. It was a sad.
投入在他身上，我深深地迷恋着他，那根本不是一种非常健康的动态关系。他让我既焦虑又兴奋，而这让我对他言听计从。正因为我当时对他如此迷恋，导致我找尽各种借口去和他的朋友们做朋友。很自然地，我花了很多时间和他们在一起、呆在他们家里，以至于我非常、非常轻易地就融入了那些友谊中。因为这当然很方便，他们就在身边，而且可能也都是很好的人。当这段恋情不可避免地结束时，我当然为不再和这个人在一起而感到崩溃和心碎，但与此同时，我也感到了另一种由失去这些友谊而带来的社会层面的痛苦。这是一个悲伤的
truth that they were his friends first, and I know that, you know, perhaps we're more mature than to think that odds is a thing, or to think that we can claim certain people as our own. But it was just the nature of how things felt, that they were more his friends than mine. And so I lost him, then I lost his friends, and then I turned around and realized that I'd lost my own friends in the process of pursuing this relationship. and I will not sweeten the sugar for you. It was really, really difficult and it was really, really hard. But this is how I went about it.
事实：他们原本是他的朋友。我知道，也许我们已经足够成熟，不再认为“划地盘”这种事真的存在，也不再认为我们可以把某些人强行据为己有。但事情给人的感觉就是这样，比起我的朋友，他们更像是他的朋友。于是我失去了他，然后失去了他的朋友，接着我转过身才意识到，在追求这段感情的过程中，我把自己的朋友也给弄丢了。我不会为你粉饰太平。这真的、真的很不容易，过程非常、非常艰难。但我是这样做的：
Firstly, I did reach out to my old friends and I was really, really honest with them. I said, you know, we've broken up. I realized that that relationship, you know, caused me to perhaps behave the way that I didn't want to. It caused me to not be as present in your life anymore. But if you'll give me the chance, I'd really like to reconnect. and just do things that are slow and steady. Some of them might say, no, that's totally okay.
首先，我确实联系了我的老朋友们，我对她们非常、非常坦诚。我说，你知道的，我们分手了。我意识到那段感情让我做出了或许并非我本意的事。它让我不再那么关注你们的生活。但如果你愿意给我一次机会，我真的很想重新建立联系。然后慢慢来，一步一个脚印。她们当中有些人可能会拒绝，那完全没关系。
But most people are kind and forgiving, and they probably really love your company. They really enjoy your company. They've probably missed you. So they'll want to bring you back into the fold. They'll want to be in your life. Reach out just to do something small, do something activity-based,
但大多数人都是善良且宽容的，她们可能真的很喜欢你的陪伴。她们真的很享受有你在一起的日子。她们可能一直都很想念你。所以她们会欢迎你重新回到她们的圈子里。她们会希望你回到她们的生活中。主动联系只是为了做点小事，做一些基于共同活动的事情，
go and get a coffee, go for a walk, and then also try and extend your circle beyond those old friends and beyond your ex-boyfriend's friends to also include people who didn't know you before, who didn't know you during, but who know you in this new phase of your life. Because it's going to be a brilliant one. The post-breakup glow-up is insane. And it's not physical, it's mental. You become this, like, enchanting version of yourself.
去喝杯咖啡，去散散步，然后试着把你的社交圈扩大到那些老朋友和前男友的朋友之外，去结识那些在你之前不认识你、在你恋爱期间也不认识你，但却在这个全新的生活阶段了解你的人。因为这将会是一段非常精彩的经历。分手后的“焕新逆袭”简直太疯狂了。而且这不是外表上的，是精神上的。你会变成这样一个迷人的自己——
Once you get through the pain and the hurt, there is just such fertile soil upon which for you to grow as an individual. and to really rediscover yourself, I think you might need some new friends for that chapter. So this really comes down to how to make friends as an adult as well. My biggest tip is to start doing the same things at the same time and the same place. Build friends around routine. So how I did this after my breakup and then I also moved to cities at the same time was that I started going to the same fitness classes on the same day at the same time.
一旦你熬过了痛苦和心碎，就会有一片极其肥沃的土壤供你作为个体去成长。为了真正重新发现自我，我想你在那个阶段可能会需要一些新朋友。所以这其实也归结为：作为一个成年人该如何交朋友。我最大的秘诀就是：在同一时间、同一地点，开始做同样的事情。围绕日常习惯来建立朋友圈。所以在分手后我是这样做的——当时我还同时搬去了别的城市——我开始在每周几的同一时间去上同样的健身课。
So I do boxing on Tuesday at 6.30 p.m. and on Thursdays at 5.30. And I knew that there would be other people who would have the same routine and structure as me, so I'd be seeing them. And through that, we were able to start slowly building a friendship. I also went to life drawing classes, and I went to a ceramics class. And I made friends that way because, you know, post-school and uni, it's always so difficult. Even, like, outside of work to make new friends, because you don't have those convenient structures.
所以我周二下午6点半去上拳击课，周四下午5点半去。我知道那里会有其他人跟我有着相同的日常习惯和生活结构，所以我总能见到他们。通过这种方式，我们开始慢慢建立起友谊。我还去上了人体素描课，还上过陶瓷课。我就是通过这种方式交到了朋友——你知道的，在离开学校和大学之后，要交新朋友总是那么难。甚至在工作之外也是如此，
But I find that, like, classes and... and weekly activities that are structured are a really great way to meet people. And also just start reaching out to mutual, start reaching out to people who, you know, you've met a couple of times at a party and who you really, really hit it off with or who are friends of friends. This is an excellent time for you to really regrow that social circle that perhaps you've been lacking. I know that it probably feels really, really daunting and maybe really lonely.
因为你没有了那些便利的社交结构。但我发现，各种课程和结构化的每周活动，真的是结识新朋友的好方法。另外，也可以开始主动联系那些共同的好友，联系那些你在派对上见过几次、一见如故的人，或者是朋友的朋友。现在正是你重新壮大那个或许有些荒废的社交圈的绝佳时机。我知道这可能让你感到非常、非常畏惧，也许此刻也会觉得很孤独。
at this point as well. But I had a really crazy realization. I really feel for you actually, because just a few days ago, I was having my friends' mess, like my friends' miss party for my friends. And I was sitting at the table and I was thinking, wow, when I first moved to Sydney after this breakup,
但我也曾有过一个极其疯狂的顿悟。其实我真的对你感同身受，因为就在几天前，我正在为我的朋友们举办一场“好友圣诞聚餐（friendsmas）”。我坐在桌旁心想，哇，当初我刚在分手后来到悉尼时，
I'd lost so many friends. And I never imagined that I'd be at this point again. And this was what I always wanted. I always wanted to have a big table full of people who I could celebrate with. And these were like 20 of my really good friends. And I remember in that time after my breakup, when I really didn't have many friends,
我失去了那么多的朋友。我从没想过自己还能回到今天这个状态。而这正是我一直以来所渴望的。我一直想要一张摆满人的大长桌，能和大家一起庆祝。这些人大概有20个，全都是我非常要好的朋友。我记得在我分手后的那段时间里，当我真的没有多少朋友时，
I'd neglected my old friendships. You know, they weren't really as strong as they could be. And I'd really, you know, rebuilt those old friendships and also found new ones. So I want you to know what's possible. Sorry, there was a long ramble, a gratitude ramble, I would say. Just to really tell you that where you are right now
我曾疏于维系过去的友谊。（你知道的，它们当时并不像本该那样牢固。）但我真的重新建立起了那些旧友谊，同时也找到了新的朋友。所以我想让你知道，一切皆有可能。抱歉，刚才扯得有点远了，可以说是一场充满感恩的碎碎念。只是想真正告诉你，你现在所处的地方，
was not where you'll be forever. Put in effort, put in time, take a year to just be single and to really concentrate on building those social circles. And also take it as a lesson that whatever next relationship you find, because you will find a new person and you will find love again, your friendships need to be equally as important because they are the things that really sustain us through every single chapter in our life. Those are all of the 20-something dilemmas that I had for you guys today. I really enjoy doing this episode. I guess I love advice giving. I love specific advice giving. And it was really nice to actually be able to have your voices on the podcast because, gosh, obviously the season of gratitude, I'm going to be all sappy and emotional again, but you guys made
绝不是你永远停留的地方。付出努力，付出时间，用一年的时间去享受单身，真正专注于建立那些社交圈。同时也要把它当成一个教训：无论你接下来找到怎样的新恋情——因为你一定会找到新的人，也一定会再次坠入爱河——你的友谊都必须占据同样重要的地位，因为正是这些友谊在人生的每一个阶段真正支撑着我们。以上就是我今天为大家准备的所有“20多岁困惑”。我真的很喜欢录制这期节目。我想我是真的很喜欢给别人提建议。我喜欢给出具体的建议。而且能把你们的真实声音放在播客里，感觉真的太棒了，因为天哪，在这个感恩的季节里，我又要变得多愁善感、情绪化了，但正是你们成就了
the show this year. You made the podcast this year. You were behind every amazing thing that I got to do, period. You know, I'm not even going to take any credit. Without you guys, it wouldn't be possible. So I really hoped that it was really nice getting to hear from other listeners that these questions resonated with you, that maybe you got answers to some of your own dilemmas. And I want to thank you from the bottom of my heart for all of the support and love that you have for the psychology of your 20s. Next year is going to be a crazy year. I have some big news. coming January 6th, some huge news. And, you know, I got to announce my book this year. So if you haven't already, make sure that you pre-order person in progress. It's coming out in April. And I will be traveling all around the world to hopefully get to meet you all at some book
今年的节目。你们成就了今年的播客。在我所做的每一件了不起的事情背后，都有你们的支持，句号。你知道的，我甚至都不想把功劳揽在自己身上。没有你们大家，这一切都是不可能实现的。所以我真心希望，听到其他听众的声音能让你们觉得很美好，这些问题能引起你们的共鸣，也许你们也从中找到了自己某些困惑的答案。我要从心底感谢你们对《20多岁的心理学》一直以来的支持与喜爱。明年将会是疯狂的一年。我有一些重磅消息要在1月6日公布，一些非常重大的消息。而且，你知道的，我今年还发布了自己的书。所以如果你们还没买的话，请务必提前预订《成长中的人》（Person in Progress）。这本书将在四月份出版。我将环游世界，希望能通过图书签售会、新书巡回活动、见面会等形式在现实中与你们所有人见面。明年我们将会有更多线下的连结，对此我感到非常、非常兴奋，因为我觉得这正是我们一直以来所缺少的。我真的很高兴能走出去，去见见一些粉丝，见见听众，见见其他同样在经历我们所经历的一切的20多岁的朋友们。所以我想说，祝大家节日快乐，新年快乐。在此之前我们肯定还会沟通，但这大概是我在此之前最后几期能够单独和大家唠嗑的单人节目之一了。
signings, at some book tours, at some meetups. We're going to have so much more in-person connection next year that I'm very, very pumped for because I feel like that's what we've been missing. I'm really excited to get out there and to meet some of the fans, meet some of the listeners, meet some of the other fellow 20-something people who are going through what we are all going through at the same time. So I want to say big, happy holidays and a happy new year. We're definitely going to talk before then, but this will probably be one of my last, you know, solo episodes where I just get to talk to you guys before then. so you have made my year not to sound like a broken record and make sure that you are following along or you're subscribed on Apple Podcasts or Spotify, leave a little review. It's a really great way to give back these holidays is to give me some kind words to read when I'm feeling anxious after my
所以你们真的成就了我这一年（听起来像是在老调重弹），请务必在Apple Podcasts或Spotify上关注或订阅，并留下一点评价。在这节日期间，回馈我的最好方式，就是在我对新年派对和计划感到焦虑时，留下一些温暖的话语让我读一读。我们很快就会再聊的。一定要把这期节目分享给你觉得也会喜欢它的朋友。那么下一次再见之前，请保持安全。保持善良。请对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。
New Year's Day party and plans. And we will talk very, very soon. Make sure to send this episode to someone you know who might enjoy it as well. And until now, Next time, stay safe. Stay kind. Please be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled. healthier person.
请收听《2%》。也就是在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO%”。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和而言是个大日子。84年对我意义重大。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。在每一集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代那样。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
84年太疯狂了。我的意思是，那太疯狂了。我觉得对于黑人群体而言，真的没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家近来可好？欢迎收听《迎难而上》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历的，我们会进行一些在其他任何地方都谈不上安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个懂得怎么做的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人披着一身铠甲？这向世界释放出一个信号：你不是好惹的。
84 was a wild. I mean, it was a wild. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
仅仅因为你具备这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《迎难而上》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改了一次检测。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案件。另外两名经历过同样遭遇的男子：
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我整个人惊呆了。
through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues,
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情感陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，
Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《情感陷阱》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集节目暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。